[音楽]
ブードゥー君
[拍手]
私は普段日本の超ド田舎を回って旅行業アドバイザーという仕事をしています
どれくらい田舎なのかといいますと最寄り駅から車で2時間とか
フェリーで5時間かかる離島とかそういうとこばっかり一定お仕事させていただいて
いるんですけれどもこういう所っていうのはだいたい
もう何をやっても反対されるんですよ新しいことをしようもうならまぁだいたい反対さ
れるんですねでそういう反対している人を見方に変えるという活動をやって
いいます
今日はその活動についてお話しさせていただきます
でもですね別に反対すてを無視してやったらいい案と思いの方がいらっしゃると思うん
ですね
私も妻そうそう思いましたでもこういう田舎ではそうはいかないんですというのも今
日本の田舎というのは移住促進をしていますで i ターン
とか地域おこし協力隊とかそういうのを聞かれた方いらっしゃると思うんですけれども
こういう方たちは新しい仕事を自分で作り出さないといけないんですねなのでその土地
に縁もゆかりもない上に
その周りの協力もないとなると本当に辛いんです
じゃあどれくらいの人が反対するのかといいますと
こういう反対されている人を何人かに話を聞いてみたんですけどももちろん人によって
差はありますが平均するとなんと
9割の人が反対するんだそうです
ほとんどが反対ですしかもですねわざわざ家まで行ってきてあの前の間違ってるみたい
な高グイグイ反対してくるんですねもう説教するぐらいの感じで
であの
今日本で新しい子日本の田舎で新しいことをしようと思うと
見方がほとんどいないというのが今の日本の田舎の現像です
こういう人たちというのはですねここまで反対されるとやっぱりだんだんやめようかな
という気になってくるんですね
私はその口づけそうになってる人も涙をたくさん見てきました
もうなんとかしないといけないということで話を聞いてもらう
一旦話を聞いてもらう場を作っ作ろうと思ったのがこの活動を始めたきっかけでした
ところで
私はだいたいたこういうことを反対する人っていうのは年配の男性なんですよ
こういう方たちのことを
最大限の愛をこめて
ツイート読んでいます
岩からですね9爺と言い始めますけれども品を失いを感じになりますけれども許して
ください
でこのジジイたちをですねなんとか
黙って話を聞かせたいと黙らせたいっていう感じなんですね私は
で最初はよくある日丁寧税のブレーンストーミングみたいな否定やめましょうみたいな
感じ
に行ったんですけどもジジイたち
全然1ハウス来ませんでした
爺ってあの人が好きかないじゃないですか
行かないですねほらね頷いてますよねほんと聞かないんですよ
であの人の話を聞くふりして俺の赤いと不幸やったんやみたいな
結局自分の自慢話をするというですねこういうことになりまして
でこうなったらど側も悪い子ですよもう
なんとかして黙って離すを聞かせたいということになりまして
禁断の過去の話封じをせました
でね確保が滑ったら黙ると思うじゃないですか
そうするとですねやっぱりうまくいったーーーですある程度の方が黙ってくださいまし
た
この加工の花数字っていうのは年齢が行けば行くほどきついルールなんですね私ぐらい
の年齢の人でも
なんかこの花過去の話封じられたら何も話すことなようなという方がいらっしゃるん
ですけど
お若い方っていうのはですね何の苦労もなくさらーっとあの
未来の話だけできるという
あのすごい一旦やっていただくとわかるんですけども
あの人間ってかコアの鳥栖とともに過去に引きずられて生きているんだなぁということ
がよくおわかりいただけると思います
これはいけるということになりまして私はの日本の各地を回って仕事をしていますので
その各地でスナックた杖といいですね
明るい地域の明るい未来の話をする飲み会という移動スナックを各地で始めました
でこのルールが先ほどのネガティブな話をしないというのと
過去の話をする
ないこの2つのルールでやっています実際どんな感じなのかといいますと
最初にこんな感じかルールがあるんで守ってくださいねとかこんな話したらどうですか
みたいなことをお話しさせていただいて直継に皆さんで話し合いをします
ねこの時に妻ソ話を聞いてもらう場を作ると言いましたけれども
聞き手と話したり別れるのではなくて参加している老若男女の方みなさんにご自分の
明るい未来の話を語っていただきます
で
あのなぜかですね皆さんあの明るい未来が話するときはちょっとニヤニヤするんですね
ではのあちこちでニヤニヤする人がいる2ですねとても素敵な光景です
で最後にあの前になにかの人に出てきていただいて
であの全員で話しているわけではないのでこの人の話素敵だなぁとか
シェアしてほしいなっていう話すの方の話を最後にあの
していただいています
でスナックた常にはですねなんとチーママ制度がありまして
日本を世界一茶連座に協力的な国するっていうのがもうもうすぐ大それた
目標を掲げていましてでも達也ままは身体一つなんですよだからもう限られてきて
しまうので一人でも多くの見方を作りたいということで
チーママたちと協力してですねこの活動
広げていこうとしています
スタッフた杖をやってどんな変化があったのかという事例をご紹介させていただきます
何年か前なんですけども
ドローンを使ったビジネスをしたいんだけど周りに猛反対されてるんですよねという
相談をある青年から
受けました
で彼の話を聞いてみるとこの地方がどんどん衰退していくももう見てられないと
だからちょっと他とは同じことをしたくないからちょっと変わったことで思い切った
ことをしたいんだということだったんですね
このまたこの時は今ほどドローンの可能性みたいなものをまだ報じられていない時代
でした
じゃあもうそのドローンの可能性と後はなと熱よとにか聴いてもらう場を設けようと
いうことで
スナック竜会をやりました
そうするとですねもう息うまくいって大そんなことを考えてくれ負担かあげたいな
お爺たち一同大感激って感じなんですけども
ってちょっと本当にうれしかったんですけどでも同時にアレっていう感じだったんです
ね皆ぜかというと大すでにこの話
何回もしてる
んですジジイたちに
で
聞いてなかったんですよねジジイたちの頭の中にはえ
ラジコンみたいなおもちゃやローン
そんなんで生活出来ると思ってるのかみたいな
でも反対の気持ちがすごいんでそう後の話全然耳に入ってなかったんですよ
これが農業この話だったら溶融ターってことでずっと耳に入ってきてたはずなんです
けどもよくわからない世界の言葉でもう引っかかってしまってたんですね
それをもう黙ってもう内事です最後まで聴いてもらったことによって彼の象瀬津の部分
とか
その他の部分を支える伝えることができて協力的になってくれました
でこの回ではスナック立つをやっている最中から
あの c 来る前の知り合いいるからちょっと電話してあの協力
ただて車出してもらうように言ってあげるわみたいな感じですねもそのスマックたちの
最中からで合わせてくれてほとんとん桃といろんなことが話が進んだんですけれども
一番反対していたジジイがですね最終的には前のめりで手伝ってくれる爺に変わりまし
た
残念ながらビジネスとして成功するかどうかというのはまだちょっとその先の問題なん
ですけれども強力という意味では大変成功した例でした
でここまで話してきてですね私と続いたちょっともバチバチの敵対関係なんだろうと皆
さん思っていらっしゃると思うんですけれども実は渡すと時1日て仲良しなんですよ
なんでかというと尊敬しているんです続いた家のことさっきの車屋さんの総会してくる
の話もそうですけど
人脈がすごいんで何かたよるとですね話せがものすごく速く進むんですねとかですね
やっぱ鳥栖のこうです
a こと言いよるんですよジジイ達ってなんか口を最後の挨拶をお願いします
ポケットのをパシッとばが閉まるようなことをやっぱり言ってくれるんですね
その他もやっぱほんとすごいんですよでその
すごい能力を若い力に使わない
ちょっと変なプライドとか5回とかで使わないのは本当にもったいないと私は思います
人間一人の力というのは本当に限られています出来る事は微々たるものです
周囲の協力があればもっとつからを発揮できるのではないでしょうか
さあ皆さんこれをご自分に当てはめて考えてみてください
親子でも夫婦でも先生と制度でも
ゾースト部下でも全く同じことが言えるのではないでしょうか
私は地方を回っていまして
すごいねついでもう本当にすごいマズメに未来を語ってくれる若者にたくさん出会い
ます
彼らの話すの菊花技ですね日本の未来はかなりの確率で明るいんですよ
あとは私たち大人がだそれをどう生かしてあげられるかだと思います
だからチャレンジしようとしていて反対されている人は諦めないで協力を得て欲しいと
思いますし反対している
反対してる引っ張ったりする人が派賛成している人も見守っている側の人は
ですねほとんどに反対していてもとにかく最後まで話を聞いてあげて欲しいと思います
伝えるということは大変難しいことですけれどもとてもずようなことです
このネガティブな話をしない過去の話をしない
この2つのルールで一度語りやってみてはいかがでしょうかありがとうございました
[拍手]